you this weekend there was a hiring
event that caters to adults with special
needs and those that like to help it's
Opportunity Village is looking to fill
the escalating need for Hands-On care
Laura negretti joining us live now to
talk about the ideal candidates Lauren
good morning good morning guys yes well
they have positions all across the board
from direct support providers to
registered nurses to custodians and
office jobs most jobs only require
compassion a desire to help and they'll
provide the training
there has always been an inequity for
people with disabilities in terms of the
workforce and this has been a challenge
since I've you know been in the business
and so we we really have to find better
ways to employ people with disabilities
and Opportunity Village is all about
doing that
well January numbers from the U.S
Department of Labor show that a 7.5
percent unemployment rate for persons
with disabilities and 3.8 percent for
those without
it would have been her getting a job
without
Opportunity Village without a job coach
or some to try to help
Daniel dudas is an ambassador at OV he
first got involved with them through
their job Discovery program at Bonanza
High School
and the job fair again is happening
Saturday 10 a.m to 1 p.m at their Okie
campus we've got full details for you on
our website at 8newsnow.com Nate over to
you